communism is often shown
as a caricature of a political system
where everything would return to the state
to clothes and even to children
but is this really the case
I explain everything to you
to understand
the distinction must be introduced
between the two types of property
i.e.
private property
and personal property
then personal property
concerns all goods
of which an individual may have use
namely his house or the furniture
that there is inside
on the other hand,
private property
she
corresponds to the possession of the means of production
Sometimes we can profit
and in socialist law to profit without working
it is considered theft
as much the definition of personal property
is very wide
as much as that of private property
she shows intransigence
example an individual
can own a sewing machine
for personal use
from the moment he uses it
to market its products
it will therefore benefit from this capital
and the object will no longer be of the order of property
personal but private property
still,
is there a right to property
but in a communist system